while the valley is expected to have a
mild Christmas holiday unlike other
parts of the country you can find fresh
snow an hour away and skiers and
snowboarders enjoying it Rick can you
have some really good snow
um like early on in the season so I love
coming here it was my first season
skiing uh last year in Utah and I went
every weekend but here for my second
season it'll do this season Lee Cannon
introduced new lift gates that Rita
guesses reloadable RFID Card RFID stands
for radio frequency identification and
it helps decrease lift lines and with
these it's a lot more efficient it's a
lot more organized the lift operators
don't have to worry about weaving
through the crowds hand scanning each
person the way this works though
whenever you arrive to Lee Canyon you're
going to use a QR code that you have
saved on your phone scan it at this
kiosk and once you scan it this lift
ticket should print and this is what
you're going to use to get on the lift
Lee Cannon began using RFID technology
in 2020 this year's liftgates were part
of its effort to continue improving the
skiing experience the gates open once it
senses a person's card the holiday
period you know amongst all ski areas
across North America are the busiest
times kids get their skis or snowboards
from Santa and they come out here so we
get a lot of volume during this period
some of the people hitting the slopes
already noticed the difference of having
these Gates usually there's like these
long lines and then they have to like
shoot you with their gun scan you put a
little scanner but uh these things are
just so much more convenient with these
it's not even a line so yeah it's
actually pretty efficient our FID also
cuts down on the use of paper as people
can just reload the plastic card at Lee
Canyon Joshua paguero eight news now and
representatives at Lee Canyon tell us
these Gates can allow staff to focus
more on customer service and help
eliminate lines over at the pass office